I know the hair has seen better days. I look like a European men's tennis player.
Better grrr. No, don't do that Helbig.
Hi guys my name is Grace Helbig
If you did not know, now you know, your life is different now
you've seen the title of this video
It's summertime everyone's getting bathing suits, everyone's trying them on the internet.
Try and get you to look at their jigglypuffs and squirtles.
Too real
so I thought I'm not better than that. I'll participate too.
Meghan Rienks did one of these videos where she saw all of these bikinis on the website called Cupshe
That were under $20 and none of them really fit her that well
so I immediately went and bought a bunch from that site
I also have some bathing suits from H&M, Forever 21
and... somewhere else
Let's just get into the bathing suit try on haul, shall we?
Oh, subscribe to this channel because this is going to be fun.
Here we go. The first one is this one from Cupshe, it is not cute...
I don't know why I got this one actually
it looks a little bit like cheap hotel wallpaper which is super cute.
If you saw a girl wearing this I think it would be safe to assume that she would do anything
for a shot of tequila. And she has.
Things that you probably couldn't even imagine if you just filled in a mad lib
Next, this cute high-waisted bikini from Forever 21 that was $17.90.
High-waisted bikinis have become really popular in like the last year
and I didn't know if I would like them
So I got a cheap one just to try it out, and it turns out
I don't like them
Next. We got nautical... come on..
We got some nautical vibes happening here
it's from Cupshe so it was under $20.
Top's got some zigzags and is a little confusing and excessive
and this is just standard Bikini bottom
Just really wanted to add a classic classy bikini to the collection
Next! Oh sexy pink string bikini. Can you even see it in this backdrop?
This is very Pepto-bismol chic.
I thought this top was funny because usually in a bikini the part that sexual perverts wanna see is up here
But this one says no no
We're going to show you this weird underside of the boob area that no one ever asks to see.
Here it is
This bathing suit is um a lot like relationships I've had, just lots of strings attached
Next, ooh
I've had this bathing suit for a year. This is billabong, so I think this is a little bit more expensive
But I just added it to the mix because it's a little different
It's like Baywatch but not as sexy cuz it's like a high-neck scenario
Prude Baywatch
And the last bikini in this haul.
It's a very classic bikini silhouette
You got your top and your bottom in grey stripes
and this is from H&M, $17.99 and $12.99. This was 30 bucks, altogether
It's less than how old I am but it'll last until I die
Nothing says cute-fun-flirty-sexy-bathing-suit-try-on-haul like a
Deep depressing look at your own mortality from time to time
Okay, I hope you guys enjoyed this sexy bathing suit try on haul
I know, it's a little bit out of what I normally do
but I hope that you guys enjoyed it all the same.
If you did give this video a thumbs up and subscribe to this Youtube channel
because I make videos Monday, Wednesday, and Friday.
You can talk to me on my social medias. I'm @GraceHelbig across the board
other than that. I don't know
*Loud coughing*
It sounds like someone that's thriving
[Brooks making weird sound effects]
*Coughing loudly*
oh coughing, sexy